is met by a large crowd of supporters
outside his home on Thursday the Supreme
Court ruled his arrest this week was
unlawful Osama bin Javed reports on the
capital Islamabad
the Islam about the high court has
granted Imran Khan unprecedented relief
multiple benches have ordered the police
not to arrest him not just in this most
recent corruption case but even charges
he doesn't know about
the former prime minister denies the
courts are doing him any favors
relief relief I am at the high court and
they had no reason to arrest me I was
abducted this is the law of the Jungle
it feels like martial law has been
declared
Fortress ransacked Army property when
Khan was arrested since he was removed
by parliament in a vote of no confidence
last year
Han has challenged the military's role
in politics and accused the senior
intelligence officer of being involved
in what he called an assassination
attempt opponents say Han is attacking
the same people who brought him to power
it's not the security agency it's one
man the Army Chief there's no democracy
in that in the Army the Army is getting
maligned by what is happening right now
the cabinet held an emergency meeting
and accused the Judiciary of double
standards
the court is an iron wall to protect
Imran Khan there is no precedent for
this not just in Pakistan but anywhere
in the world while baseless cases are
being formed against us the courts were
blocking investigations into Khan's
corruption
the alliance of parties that forms the
government has blamed Khan for the
violence in looting this week accusing
him of calling planning and carrying out
attacks on public facilities leaders
have lashed out to the courts
specifically the Chief Justice of
Pakistan the ruling Alliance has
announced a show of force against
Pakistan Supreme Court which it accuses
of showing bias in favor of Imran Khan
and as thousands of political workers
from all sides are all set to come to
the streets this season of political
uncertainty in Pakistan is far from over
Islamabad